DEMOCRATIC BUDDIES.
>> Tucker: WHAT PUT ALL OF THE
DUMB PEOPLE ON TV?
YOU ARE NOT ONE OF THEM.
SEVERAL TECH CEOS DEMANDED THAT
REGULAR PEOPLE BE DEPRIVED OF
THEIR RIGHT TO CARRY FIREARMS.
THE TWITTER CEO TWEETED THIS:
HE ENDORSED DEMANDS SHOULD BY
THE MARCH FOR OUR LIVES.
INCLUDING BANNING HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES AND TAKING ALL WEAPONS
THAT ARE ASSAULT WEAPONS.
IN 2015, TWITTER SPENT MORE THAN
$68,000 PROVIDING PERSONAL
SECURITY TO JACK DORSEY.
WERE THOSE GUARDS UNARMED?
NO, THEY WERE NOT.
PHIL PANE ADVISED FOR HILLARY
CLINTON'S 2016 CAMPAIGN.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
IT'S HARD TO READ THIS AS
ANYTHING ELSE BUT AN EFFORT BY
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE TO BRING
MORE POWER TO THEMSELVES WHICH
IS WHAT PEOPLE IN CHARGE DO.
WE GET THE GUNS.
YOU DON'T.
SHUT UP AND OH BAY.
-- OBEY.
WHY IS THAT NOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
RIGHT WAY TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
I ENJOYED LISTENING TO YOUR
CONVERSATION WITH YOUR COLLEAGUE
EARLIER.
I AM INTERESTED TO ARE THAT YOU
THINK IT'S FUNNY SOMEONE ON TV
THOUGHT A SODA CAN OPENING WAS A
GUNSHOT, YOU THOUGHT IT WAS A
FUNNY.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT IT WAS
IDIOTIC.
THAT STUDIO DOESN'T HAVE BEGUN
SHOTS.
IT WAS A SODA OPENING.
IF YOU ADVOCATE FOR POSITIONS,
YOU NEED TO LEARN ABOUT THE
TOPIC.
I AM NOT DENIGRATING THE FEAR
PEOPLE FEEL IN THE FACE OF
GUNFIRE.
LOOK, THE POINT IS ORDINARY
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID.
WE AGREE ON THAT.
WHY WOULD THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
WHO ARE PROTECTED BY ARMED
SECURITY DEMAND THAT NO ONE ELSE
BE ALLOWED TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES?
>> WELL, I HAVE FRUSTRATION WHAT
I HEARD FROM THE TWITTER CEO FOR
A DIFFERENT REASON.
I DON'T LIKE THIS TREND WE HAVE
OF WAITING FOR GUN VIOLENCE TO
COME TO YOUR BACKYARD BEFORE YOU
CARE ABOUT IT.
JUST BECAUSE A TECH COMPANY
YESTERDAY, YOU GOT A LETTER FROM
ALL OF THE TECH CEOS WHO DECIDED
TO SIGN ON.
I WAS TOUCHED BY GUN VIOLENCE.
A FELT STRONGLY ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE AND ALL OF THE CONCERNS
BEFORE THAT.
IT DOESN'T TAKE THAT ISSUE TO
PIQUE MY INTEREST.
IT'S INTERESTING, TUCKER, A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO WATCH THIS SHOW
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WATCH
THIS NETWORK FEEL THE SAME WAY I
DO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE POLLS --
>> Tucker: I FEEL THE SAME WAY
YOU DO.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
LET'S BE HONEST.
ONE OF THE PIECES OF POLITICAL
RHETORIC THAT DRIVES ME CRAZY IS
ONLY A SELECT FEW CARE ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE.
MOST PEOPLE ARE HORRIFIED BY GUN
SHOOTINGS.
I AM.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE?
WHAT IS THE WISE THING TO DO?
IT'S NOT OVER WHO CARES AND WHO
DOESN'T?
EVERYBODY CARES.
COME ON NOW.
>> I WOULD TURN THAT QUESTION
BACK TO YOU:
WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
>> Tucker: A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
WITH THE PARKLAND SHOOTING A
WELL DOCUMENTED STRING OF
FAILURES BY PEOPLE WHOSE JOB IT
WAS TO PROTECT THE KIDS IN THAT
SCHOOL.
THERE WERE 4 ARMED COPS THAT
HEARD THE GUNFIRE AND DIDN'T GO
IN.
I NEVER HEARD THEIR NAMES
MENTIONED AT THE MARCH FOR THEIR
LIVES.
I NEVER HEARD ANYBODY MENTION
THAT.
WE HIRED PEOPLE TO PROTECT THOSE
KIDS.
IT'S THE NRA'S FAULT?
THAT'S INSANE.
THAT'S PURE POLITICS.
>> SORRY, I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU.
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
FAILED THOSE CHILDREN.
SOME WERE THE PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
RUN INTO THE BUILDING.
A NUMBER WERE IN THE STATE HOUSE
ON CAPITOL HILL IN WASHINGTON,
D.C.
THOSE PEOPLE ALSO FAILED.
YOU COULD HAVE ACTED AFTER SANDY
HOOK.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: I LOVE.
THIS YOU ARE DEPENDING THE
PEOPLE IN POWER AS EVERYONE IN
THE LEFT DOES.
THE PEOPLE IN POWER ARE
BLAMELESS.